All right, there's the link, guys. Yeah,
you can still see hints of it in the
Quran because Allah calls himself we.
Clearly, the Trinity.
>> You see the Trinity right there. Right
there. See, there's remnances
of the the Trinity and the Quran, the
true Quran affirming the real Bible.
Okay.
>> So, man, they coming in.
Pop. Good gracious. Bobby, what's up,
man?
>> Hey, guys.
>> What's up, Bobby Cannon? I like I like
that. looking like a shake. Can you hear
us?
>> Yes, sir.
>> That was probably a little delay. Can
you hear us,
>> sir? There you go. Say say something.
Say something.
>> Hello.
>> Okay, there we go. Yeah, we're good.
>> What's up?
>> YouTube the YouTube tab.
>> So, what's on your mind, man? Yeah. You
uh you enjoyed the stream today, bro?
>> Yes, sir. I had uh messaged you guys
earlier about, you know, just going too
dark and stuff. And I think you guys uh
I don't take a lot of advice from a lot
of people on this. I truly trust them.
So you guys uh I feel like you are
grounded. So
>> the idea of being able to not go too
dark, that's uh I appreciate it.
>> Yeah, man. God bless you, bro.
Absolutely. Absolutely. Um so just is is
there anything that's uh on your mind
now? Um you maybe have another question
for us or
>> No, you guys were just, you know, uh
very lighthearted. So I was like I'm
going to click the link.
people jump on or not. So,
>> come on through and hang and and you
know, share a few words with us, man.
>> No, but uh yeah, I mean, we uh I don't
know. We like to we like to have fun,
man. We like to have fun while giving
the gospel, man. It's the joy of the
Holy Spirit. It's just it's fun. It's
fun spreading the truth, Bobby. It's fun
spreading the truth, you know.
>> I I agree. I I I love I love to study. I
love to read. I I it's just I'm really
isolated so I don't really get out and
talk to a lot of people so I don't
really I don't have the like for example
like I I watch you guys you guys light
people up when people come around
everyone lights up everyone gets you
know and when I come in I have more of a
if you guys know you know Duck Dynasty
the field guy you know
>> I have more of that kind of moment you
know when I come in I'm like you know
it's just straightforward and I I feel
like I shut people down. So, I'm trying
to learn, you know, like IP was saying
to to be humble,
>> but at the same time, I don't know how
to get people to to listen.
>> Yeah.
>> See, it seems obvious to me when you get
information to process it logically and
just accept the logical Christ.
>> Seems like that's the obvious move,
right? Like the no-brainer.
>> Yeah. how you how you continue to talk
with these with Muslims and they just
they literally walk in illogical circles
and I the Muslim shuffle is so real.
Like how real, bro? It's so it's it's so
real. I I I like to keep in mind that,
you know, we we I usually, you know,
have like 3,000 listeners. So for them
hearing me deal with even somebody who
is hard-headed, they're still seeing the
arguments laid out. They're learning the
topic, learning the arguments, learning
the tactics of the Muslim and the
tactics that I'm given. So even when I'm
dealing with a hard-headed person, it's,
you know, the people are learning from
that. And so then when they deal with
somebody who's open, it's so much more
easier when they when they find that
person. So they already know how to deal
with a difficult person. When they come
to an openhearted person, it'll be it'll
be easy. It'll be no piece of cake, you
know. But yeah. Yeah. do it doing it
doing it for the big picture, not
necessarily for the person I'm I'm
talking to directly, even though of
course we hope they come to Christ, but
you know, if they hard-headed, we we
recognize that. Yeah.
>> But yeah, thanks thanks Bobby. Thanks
for coming up and hanging out with us,
man.
>> Thank you guys. Appreciate it.
>> For sure, man. For sure. God bless you,
brother. All right, man. I got another
one of my one of my my my co-workers in
the house, man.
>> What's up, Logic? What's up, IP? What's
up, man?
>> I just wanted to come up and fanboy a
little bit, man. Um, IPs want to, you
know, I love that dude. Just wanted to
say I watch his videos. He actually
commented on one of my videos recently.
>> No, I commented on a cooking session you
had.
>> Yeah. And I just wanted to come up and
say, man, when I seen that, I took a
screenshot. I sent
>> He did. He commented on my video.
>> He sent it to our group chat, man. I was
I was like, "Yeah." But that I mean, he
did that. He was he was word y'all. By
the way, guys, if y'all didn't know,
this is the face of Hey, man. Watch your
head, man. That this
>> This is him, man. Who? He the one who
came up with that and it sto We need to
get some mugs. We need to get a shirt
and we need to get that out where we
need to get a mug cuz I'm about to start
doing I like IP style little shorts and
videos.
>> Yeah. I need I need to watch your head
mug, man.
>> I got you. I got you. You got to with
some with some of your vendors and see
what we can come up with, man.
>> Man, that's that's life, man. Life life
is the one who came up with the Thanks
for coming. He made that himself. So, I
don't know. I don't know. But yeah, if
y'all be making mugs out there and
little, you know, shirts. That's what we
want. We want a Watch your head. Watch
your head mug and [__]
>> I got I can hook you up. I know people.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, let me get, you know,
let me Hey, if I can get in touch with
the Mike Jones. I'm from, you know,
Houston area and Mike Jones, you know,
that rings a a bell around here,
>> you know, but I just wanted to come up
and just say, man, love IP. Love you.
You know, I love your Logic. And uh I
don't know if I was been able to ever,
you know, formally meet IP. So, this was
my chance. So, I had to come up and uh
seize the opportunity, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> We'll be Don't worry, we'll be we'll be
moving around the country doing this,
going there, going to different
conferences. We'll eventually meet up
somewhere.
For sure. For sure.
>> You gotta start coming out of your cave
word. Gotta start coming out, man.
>> I'm working on that. I'm working on
that, dude. Because you, you know, you
part of the squad. So, it's I would love
for you to come with me, man. I London
Speakers Corner,
>> New York,
>> Santa, LA, you know, I don't know if
what if we if if you know they doing um
I plan to hit the start hitting the
colleges. if you can come with me to the
colleges out there in Texas and you know
I would I would love that. So yeah just
work work on that man.
>> I'm working on that. I'm working on that
man. I just want to say man y'all are
inspiration you know to everybody not
just apologies to everybody man. And I
>> you're doing good stuff though man. I
watched some of your stuff uh this week.
He's doing good.
>> He almost got me too.
>> Come on. See he he he trying man.
>> He almost got me man.
>> Trying it. Hey, I appreciate it though.
IP I appreciate it, man. I'm going, you
know, consume more your content and
stuff. So,
>> thank you.
>> You going live?
>> Not tonight. I'm I'm reading some some
stuff. I'm
>> Okay, studying. I'm studying a little
bit of stuff.
>> Yeah. Got to yourself.
>> Read 10 pages a day at least is what I
tell.
>> 10 pages a day to keep the dummies away.
>> I'mma put that on a shirt.
>> 10 pages. 10 pages. You can't steal it
now. You can't. You got it. You can you
you can you can have it. You can have
it. Appreciate it, man. God bless you.
>> Love your word.
>> Love you.
>> Peace, man.
>> All right. What's going on, Simon?
>> I'm good. Can you hear me?
>> I can hear you. I can hear you, brother.
>> Yeah. Um I just want to say thank you
for all the things you've been doing. Um
IP, I'm a huge fan. I'm a I'm a massive
fan. I just want to say God bless you.
Um
>> you too, man.
>> Our thoughts and prayers are with you
guys with what happened to Charlie. It's
devastating. It's still surreal. I don't
know if I can recover from this. So, and
I have worry so much for you guys. You
guys are on the front lines. You hit the
streets. You walk on the roads. A lot of
people don't like what you say. A lot of
people disagree what you say. And well,
it's I I just pray I pray God be God
help you. Yeah. Because it's it's it's
harsh. Um the the cost of disciplehip is
sometimes death. And um as Christians,
we must be ready um for for this. So,
it's I I really don't know. Um I'm
grateful for speaking with you guys
today. Um my thoughts and prayers are
with you guys. Um Logic if you want to
start hitting this the campuses. I
figure I think you might want to set up
a GoFundMe so we can support you so that
you can get securities as well because
um
>> losing Charlie is is is one thing.
Losing it would never happen though. I
don't want to like say but I mean
>> this is and Christians listening this is
an opening now. We we shouldn't back
down. We got to silence us. We are safe.
We're facing persecutions now from every
corner. The leftist, the Muslims,
everybody. So, we've got to be ready.
This these are trying times and um these
times have happened in our history
before and we should be ready. Um thank
you so much for all the work you do. Um
thank you so much. I am so grateful. God
bless you,
>> man. God bless you, man.
>> Remember, Simon, God knows what's going
to happen. He knows the path. He knows
all the martyrs. Yeah,
>> they will all be avenged and justified.
Charlie will get his he will be back in
a new body one day just like all of us.
This isn't over. This is this is just
one of the end of the chapters for some
people. But guess what? There's still so
many more to come and we will all be
victorious. We know how this ends.
>> It's I know but sometimes it's so hard
to swallow. It's
>> I literally was falling yesterday. I I
couldn't watch Avery's live yesterday
because he was crying. I was crying. I
mean, Charlie, using the past tense now
for Charlie. He was He was
>> He was He used to It's surreal. It's
unbelievable.
>> I met him last month. He was super nice,
cared. He believed in what we're doing
here, too. He wanted to support us. We
were going to He was like He was talking
about all these dreams he wanted to do
to get apologetics done and out. We're
going to make it happen. I was talking
to Ridon. It's This is We're not His His
dreams are going to come true and we're
going to make sure they happen.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thank you so much for having
me.
>> Thank you for encouraging us, Simon.
Thank you for praying for us, man. Um, I
think that that is a good idea for the
GoFundMe. Um,
>> with with everything that does happen
that that did like set me back in in how
I want to think about operating and
going out and so especially the college
campuses because we can see that what
happens on a college freaking campus,
man. So,
>> yeah.
>> Um, yeah, I think that's a good idea.
So, for those of you guys who think it's
a good idea and you guys want to see,
>> you know, a college tour, a God logic
apologetics college tour,
>> um, yeah, I think a GoFundMing will be a
good idea. So, people we get some real
security
>> because because the the super chats and
the the YouTube money is not going to
it's not going to foot the bill for
sure, right? And we don't want the the
leftist or the the persecutors to feel
like we're backing down. We're afraid.
We need to have more people be seen,
giving the word, you know, thousand and
one more Charlies and um Yeah. So, we're
going to support you whichever way we
can every
>> God bless you, Simon. Thank you, man.
You have a good rest of your day, bro.
>> You too. You too. Bye-bye.
>> Peace. Peace.
>> All right. What up, sis? What the deal?
>> What's good? What's good,
>> man? He said the original the original
could come up. I was like, bro, I'm
calling the stream. Oh, that's that's
right.
>> Today's Today's my birthday, so it's a
good birthday gift to be able to talk to
both of y'all.
>> Oh, man. Praise God. Yeah. Happy
birthday. Happy birthday, Nicole.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. To be
honest with you, I didn't really have
nothing to say. I just wanted to say
what's up. Um, and just thank you for
allowing us to come up. You know, being
a Christian that obeys, like don't call
in. I don't understand. I be getting so
frustrated when you're on the stream. I
be mad for you. I'm like, he just asked
and they be like, "Oh, but I just have a
quick question." Like, bro, watch the
streets. Like, why are you
>> I'm not I'm not a Christian. But, uh I
just question,
>> Nicole.
>> Yeah. I I don't I don't understand it. I
don't get it. I don't know if God if
it's God like testing me on purpose, you
know, like, oh, they think you patient.
Let's really see how real really patient
you, you know, let's really build your
patience,
>> man.
>> And it makes us look bad. Like, can
y'all not exercise active listening cuz
I feel it like you never know how many
people you can get through the stream to
actually reach one Muslim to reach the
gospel and then you got Christians on
here acting stupid.
>> So we we get annoyed too. Um
>> yeah I've been seeing y'all comments.
Y'all be going off, bro. Y'all be going
straight off. Do you remember you were
on a stream like two weeks ago and you
had got a super chat that said, "Hey,
maybe you should have a stream with IP
where you um challenge the open
transmission of the Bible versus the
closed transmission of the Quran." And
you said, "Okay, I'mma do that."
>> Yes. Yes.
>> That was me. I
>> What do you think about that?
>> What was it? Open transmission of the
Quran. So, so I was saying like we we
should have a you guys should have a
stream where because you know how
Muslims are quick to challenge that the
Bible is, you know, quote unquote
corrupted because we have so many
different translations or this that and
the third. However, the fact that Usman
burned all of the Qurans and made one
Quran and mass transmitted it, it would
be good to like line up fact for fact,
history for history. why it's better
that we had an open transmission versus
the Muslims with their closed um
>> transmission and just how you can
compare you can yeah cuz you you don't
have anything to fact check the Quran to
the one that Usman that he masked we
don't have anything to fact check it to
because the other ones were burned
whereas with the Bible we can see what
we can wait and compare you know
different manuscripts of like what this
manuscript says versus this you can see
what family of manuscripts it falls in
So,
>> oh yeah,
>> why is he getting up?
>> I don't know. He like took off.
>> Me?
>> Yeah. Here. Here,
>> bro. This is actually my This is my
second time talking to you and I've been
studying. I've I
>> grab the chef's hat because you're
cooking. Grab it. There you go. There
you go.
>> Thank you.
>> You guys should watch You should watch
an interview I did with Dan Wallace.
He's a scholar on the biblical
manuscript transmissions. We did it like
I think in July. He went through a lot
of data on that. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's really good because like the
gentleman that y'all was talking to, the
young man who I think he's hi, but he's
not 100% sure because you can't really
be a Hebrew Israelite and think other
people are going to be saved. So, I
don't know what camp he's in. Anyways,
his argument is he sounds leery on like
the historicity of the Bible and the
text and the events that happened
stating that, you know, Constantine was
a bad person, but it's like that's not
factually true. Like, where are you
pulling your facts from? like let's talk
about actual facts com and compare it to
what's you know conflation. So, I was
like, that would just be a really good
topic. And I was actually um I'm on a
I'm in a little group chat in Discord
where like I'm the only Protestant, but
I study with some apostolics. And one of
them dropped me into I was in a my first
like debate with a Muslim and we were
debating the gospel of Q. And it was
comical because bro, I was cracking up
and I didn't want to be rude, but his
main defense was like the the the
narrative of Christ's resurrection is up
for debate because, you know, Q says
this and this, but the other gospels
don't. And I'm like, how can you I'm
like, how can you argue the validity of
Q stating that the gospel narrative is
not in it when the the scholars that
you're using to pull from agree we don't
know what Q is and we don't know what it
said because we don't have the
manuscript. And then he was using Bart
he was using Bartman to be like well
Bartman says this. I said sir read the
page that you posted. He is stating, "I
don't know. We don't know what Q
actually said." And if you and his
argument was, "Well, Q is pulling from
the that the Gospels were pulled from
Q." And I said, "Okay, so if you're
stating that the gospel narrative is not
in Q, but Matthew, Mark, and Luke pulled
from Q, then that means that the gospel
narrative is in the Gospel of Q. You
can't say that it's not there." So, he
didn't he didn't message back after
that. And I went back to my group chat
and I was like, "Yo, I think I won. I
think I won the first pick."
>> Oh, you got them because Yeah. Yeah. Q
is a total total mess trying to figure
out what that is. Uh it's like someone
even did a really cool study. They
looked at Matthew and Luke and they're
like, "Can we reconstruct Mark from what
we have in Matthew and Luke?" And he was
like, "No, no." His his last name was
Weeks, but he wrote a paper on this and
just you can't even reconstruct Mark
from just Matthew and Luke. How are we
going to reconstruct a document we don't
even have? Which is cute. we don't even
have and if and then he was mad at me
because he was like, "Well, we don't
have any source text for Q." And I said,
"On the contrary, we do. We have
Matthew, Mark, and Luke because that's
the only source text that this this
conflation argument is coming from. If
you're stating that we don't have Q, we
do have it because we have Matthew,
Mark, and Luke. And you're stating that
what's not in them, you're extracting
from Q." I Yeah,
>> that's really good. You You nice with
it. You nice with it.
>> You You've been watching God Logic, man.
You you you nice one
>> man. Between between between you between
you IP um I actually watch a lot of um
do you guys know a young man named Aan?
>> Yes. Yeah. He's oriental.
>> He's oriental orthodox. Um I actually
get to I study Bear the Image does a a
deep dive into the Gospel of Matthew
every Monday. So I hop on to his and
then plus the apostolics that I study
with. So, I like try to stay in it cuz I
don't think I'm ready to like be talking
to people like all of the time, but I'm
confident enough when a conversation
hops up like, "No, that's not right or
this isn't right or this is what your
text actually says." So,
>> you guys are doing good workspiring
people.
>> Have you have you have you went on the
offensive yet? Meaning, have you ever
started the conversation yourself
before?
>> I'm just always You know what? It
depends. Like I'm a ride show driver. So
if people get in my car and the topic of
God comes up that they initiate, then I
walk right through the door. Or if
somebody says something, I'll make a
statement that will cause them to make a
statement and then I kind of like open
the door that way. Did that answer your
question?
>> Yep. It sure does. It sure does. Gotcha.
Yeah.
>> Well, that's awesome. That's awesome,
Nicole. I I appreciate you coming up
here finally and joining the live, man.
you know.
>> Amen. And last thing, you ever going to
find yourself in Philly? Do you ever
plan on doing anything in Philly? In
Philly?
>> I want to I want to come to Philly, but
I there not everybody in my team wants
to go to Philly cuz they think Phillyy's
too.
>> No, my mom my my mom is from Philly and
my brother lives there. He actually is
an evangelist and the Hebrew Israelite
scene and the Muslim scene is strong
there. So, my brother, he literally be
out and about in the streets like
talking.
>> I would I would love to come to Philly.
I want to do I want to do what I did in
New York. I want to come to go to Philly
and do the same thing.
>> Okay. I will I will email you and I will
give you my brother's information. He's
called the reach and he be Ryan is one
of those Christians that will stand on
the corner and defend the gospel. Like
he he sent me a video where it was him
and he was surrounded by like 30 Hebrew
Israelites and he just he just stood
there. He just stood there and defended
the faith. Um there's parts of Philly
that are dangerous, but for the most
part it's no worse than New York. And as
long as you know where you at, you
straight. So I can connect you um with
my brother for sure.
>> Yeah, that'd be awesome. Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> sounds like a plan.
>> God bless you both.
>> You too.
>> Me, too.
>> God, thank you. Thank you for what
you're doing and I I'm I'mma take his
advice and do the 10 pages a day because
I want to get my reading like way up.
>> Me too. I'mma do it, too.
>> I'mma do it, too. God bless you, Nicole.
>> God bless you, too. Have a good night.
>> You too.
>> Adam, what's up, man?
>> This is crazy, man. Can y'all hear me?
>> Yeah, we can hear you. Nice and good,
man.
>> All right. All right. Yeah. Uh yeah,
man. You guys are I mean such an extreme
inspiration for me, man. I mean, uh IP I
watched, you know, your uh case for the
resurrection stuff, you know, like
couple years after it came out. I mean,
it was a it was changed my my whole
worldview. Uh I've with you too and and
uh and William Lane Craig as well are
just like the absolute goats for me.
I've converted three of my friends. I
got one on the way using your arguments,
using things from you guys.
>> I mean, it's uh, you know, life-changing
stuff you guys are doing. Of course, you
guys know this, but um,
>> everyone,
>> I don't care if the arguments work. Just
plagiarize me. I don't care.
>> Right. Right.
>> Yeah. And it eventually gets to the
point they start asking a little too
much philosophy and I'm like, I got the
guy for you. I know. Like, let me let me
suggest, you know. Um, but yeah. Yeah.
So that there's, you know,
>> uh,
>> but yeah, you guys, yeah, just the work
y'all doing, never stop. And of course
on recent events, um, definitely be
careful, right? Um, you not to bring all
that back, but just um I know we've all
felt that in the very spiritual pain
>> with what happened and uh but as as we
all know, not just that we win in the
end, but we've already won, you know, so
and we'll, you know, see him again, but
always, yeah, be careful when you
traveling, guys. We love that. Love you
guys. Keep doing what you're doing. And
uh yeah,
>> thank you, brother. Thanks for the
encouragement, man. Shout out to you.
Shout out to your little girl, you guys.
>> All right. Later.
>> Peace. Peace. All right. What's going
on?
>> Yo, what's up, brother? What's your
name, brother?
>> Jason.
>> J Jason.
>> Jason. I'm from Australia.
>> Okay. For sure. For sure. I almost
called you Jason.
>> I was just there in May.
>> Hey.
>> Yeah. Just I was in Brisbane in May.
>> Brisbane.
>> Yeah. Brisbane.
>> How you doing, man?
>> Good. Good. I just wanted to say RIP to
Charlie Kirk, mate. All I wanted to say.
>> Just like the last said, we all felt
that one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's bad.
>> Um Oh, and and do you do you actually
think um what's his name? Prophet
Muhammad was a was a true prophet.
>> You you asking us?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, Quran only Muslims,
man. I don't I don't understand.
>> So, only Christians, I mean.
>> So, all right. So, so no bro. So what
what what it is is is Muslims come to us
and they always say to us that
>> the Bible we have is corrupted.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> They say they say they believe in the
original before it got corrupted.
>> Okay.
>> So all well what what we've done is we
flipped the tables. We say okay fine. We
believe in the original Quran before it
got corrupted.
>> Yeah.
>> And Muhammad was a they say Jesus was a
Muslim. We say Muhammad was a Christian.
>> Yep.
>> But they corrupted his message and story
and made him out to look like a Muslim.
>> I understand.
>> Yeah, it's all good. I'll save you.
>> Take care. All right. Bullet Antioch,
what's up, man?
>> Hello, brothers. IP and God logic. My
first time. I cannot stop smiling. Oh my
gosh. Shout out to the NSD, National
Slavic District of AG in America. us
Slavs, we don't get enough recognition,
but man, you guys are doing the fight
IP. Your stuff is meat. Spiritual meat.
Like, dude,
>> you have to prep for it.
>> I saw your Trinitarian stuff and God
logic. Oh my gosh, I'm just so happy you
exist. I've been getting into I've been
getting into conversations with the
Muslims on Discord
>> and oh my gosh the shock they give me
when they reply with AI like Chad GPT
responses
>> AI because they're like I I you make a
very good point however have you
considered like that's not the
>> like seventh century scripture doesn't
necessarily mean originality
>> like I'm like guys what are you doing I
talk to I talked to a brother. Well,
he's not a brother, but you know, he's a
brother. And uh he was bringing up
morality in Islam. He's like, "Muhammad,
the most the best example for all
mankind." I'm like, "What? Why do you
guys pick schools of thought? You want
to eat like crawfish, you got to go with
this school of thought. You want to look
at a woman before you're married, you go
with the hanbalis." And they're like,
"Oh, no. Only unrighteous Muslims do
that."
>> Yeah.
>> Only like people that really want to do
something. I'm like, well, I just saw a
J in doc
video on Ali Dawa
>> telling Sneo in Muslim lantern that he
was in the Hanbali school of thought
before he was picking a wife and he get
to see her figure before marriage and he
was like, "Oh, Ali Dawa did that." I'm
like, "Brother, you got to He's like
source of sources." I sent him all the
links, but man, you guys, you're doing
God's that's God's will. And you and you
know how Jesus said, "Pray anything in
my name and he will give it to you. If
it's in God's will, he will give it to
you." And he wills this. And uh I just
pray for you guys. And my name by the
way, Bulis and Antioch,
>> one of my favorite hadits that proved
that
>> Paul, the first original Quran, only
Pentecostal.
>> Yeah, that's good.
>> The biggest Pentecostal man of all
mankind, the St. Bull. Oh man,
>> he represents us.
>> St. God bless you guys.
>> God bless you guys.
>> You too, man. Take care, bro. Thanks for
coming up, my man. That's awesome.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Now, we got a couple of our
sisters coming up. We'll go uh for 15
more minutes.
>> That's fine. Yeah. 15.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We like close out after that.
>> Word on box. What's up, sis?
>> You thought you were going to talk crap
in the uh in the in the chat on uh on on
Tik Tok and you thought I wasn't going
to come up here and wait. What's up?
>> The video. I I don't know what you're
talking about. I in no video it never
happened. I don't know what you're
talking about.
>> Dang. I don't know what I did. I All you
said listen you and the word and I you
guys said sis you got to start talking
more. You got to get out there. I say
okay fine. And then I get up there and
start cooking the heck out of a Muslim.
And I win. I win. Okay. I win the debate
and you you get in there and say he
cooked me. How dare you? the betrayal. I
don't see
>> Let me let me tell you. Let me tell you
hazing. You're initiating me. I don't
want the initiation. Look, take your
initiation and ask Allah to stick it.
Okay.
Allah Allah ordained and decreed that
this is how we are to bring newbies into
the fold. You have to go through the
initiation process and you got to get
the full Muslim treatment. Okay? So
whenever you cook a Muslim and you're in
a Christian life and there's no more
Muslim, they're silent because their
brother just got cooked, it's on me to
step up and say, "Alhamdulillah, he
cooked you. He destroyed you." You see,
it's on me to do that. Okay? So even
though you I guess, if I'm speaking from
an objective standpoint, demolished
every single Muslim that came on the
stage, it was freaking crazy.
>> Thank you very much. me as Allah logic.
You got cooked. You need and you need to
see that regardless the Muslim farts.
Alhamdulillah, he won. Period.
>> All right. Listen. All right. All right.
Listen. Fine. All right. I'm over it.
Listen. Point. Point two. Were you there
in the beginning? I have Have you uh
witnessed my superpower? All obviously
given to me by God. Lord Lord him Lord
himself has given me this superpower.
Did you witness what I did?
>> What what what superpower is this? was
>> Have you Have you noticed um I don't
know if you saw, but the uh the brothers
and sisters, your brothers and sisters
on TikTok specifically, they can tell
you. You can ask Bri. She was there.
They ran out of Muslim. There was no
Muslims actually requesting for that
live.
>> You join.
>> No, no, no. Listen, I didn't just I
didn't just join. I pre said it. I said,
"Listen, I can get you a Muslim. I I
manifest them." And I have Jeremiah I
have I have six Jeremiah verses that I
read out loud because these Jeremiah
verses converted me. So I test I tell my
testimony with these six Jeremiah
verses. By the time I get halfway I'm
sorry it was actually by the time I got
full way through number one we had at
least two Muslims up requesting. And Bri
said Bri goes I know you're lying. I
said no. I told you guys this is my
superpower and I know how to do it. So,
I just want to let you guys ever know if
you're running dry, just let me know.
I'll be your bait.
>> Absolutely. Well, we we'll use you as
the little hook, you know, to hook me
in. Okay.
>> Absolutely. Happy to do it. Um third, I
have one last thing to say. Sorry, we're
I'm chat I'm chatting a lot.
>> We chilling.
>> So, I actually I you know, God rest his
soul. Um I took his death pretty hard.
Charlie's I didn't know him. My my
fiance laughs at me. He's like, "Is this
your first celebrity death?" And I, you
know, I didn't grow up with like TV much
or anything. So, um, and I'm like, "No,
I think I'm taking this hard because I
don't see him as a celebrity cuz he said
it so very often. I'm nothing but flesh
and bones, right?" And it's like I I
I've never actually connected with
somebody who was so grounded and yet did
so much. So, I admired him because he
didn't idolize himself. That's why I
admired him and that's why it was so
hard, you know, and but at the same time
I I I share in the spirituality and the
comfort of our Lord knowing that
literally Charlie closed his eyes and
opened it and probably heard the words
you you have done well. So I I just know
it and the he's he was preaching till
you know his final breath essentially in
the last in his last day. So that's what
just comforts me and it's always going
to comfort me and I hope it comforts
everyone else. Um, but I do want to say
that I did hear you earlier and I do
want to um offer this. Um, if you ever
come into the Midwest at all and you're
interested, my fiance, he's a forensic
scientist, but he goes into universities
all the time. Um, sometimes he teaches
per semesters. Um, and me myself, I
actually teach. I actually I'm in the
forensic field, but I gave up my job and
I'm going to get tearful again. um
actually because of Charlie Kirk
mentioning that kids are not learning
how to read and write and I actually
went into the teaching field. So I teach
now it was my big with my big glorious
degree that I no longer think is big and
glorious because I realized that my big
and glorious degree really was just
fancy when in reality I mean and don't
get me wrong it is a hard science and
everything but he had a point. We can't
help children build their hopes and
dreams if we're showing them things that
or if we're teaching them things that
are not in the grasp of reality or
necessity. And I didn't really believe
him. I I wanted to dislike Charlie. And
I think that's why I admire him so much
because I was that person that went and
got a hard science/mmathematical
degree, right? And then I went now and
I'm like teaching kids and dude, they're
like four years behind. Like they don't
really know how to read. they don't know
how to write and I'm teaching upper
level grades and he's not wrong. We have
greatly failed. And so I do want to ask
if you do ever want to come to the
Midwest um specifically, please get in
contact with me because my fiance goes
into universities and me myself, I go
into um middle schools and high schools,
although I am certified, I I can also go
into colleges as well. I'm happy to see
to to show for you around. Um, and my
fiance actually works for the
department. We can see if we can let
them know and what we can do ahead of
time.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> sounds good. Sounds good. Yeah. Well,
we're we're linked, so we'll we'll uh
we'll talk.
>> Yeah, I'm in I'm I'm in the glorious
Midwest where there's lots of Hebrew
Israelites. So, um
yeah, they're they're actually
>> they got my attention right now, man. I
They're like,
you know,
>> they're actually a little too close for
comfort. They they were just a few
blocks down the other day and now
they're down the street and I'm just
annoyed now they're
>> I'm so jealous. I barely get to see I
ran into a group of Hebrews one time
when I that I've been out here and they
and they don't go to the same spot. They
don't there's no way to find them.
They're very secretive with where they
go. I see. Man,
>> they know you're hunting them.
>> Yeah.
>> They know you they know you're looking
for them.
>> So
>> Oh, they they post up at gas stations
over here. It's really weird. And they
and they're always in they're always in
colorful t-shirts like all together.
It's either like purple or red or
something. And that their signs say um
Jesus was a negro. Sorry, I'm just
reading just saying what the sign said.
Um and so that's how usually how they
capture people's attention. But I've
talked to them one time and I got a shut
up bit.
>> Yep. That's how they talk to that's how
they talk to the sisters who don't know
their identity. I did realize that and I
will never do that again cuz I am not
that great at like I'm okay. It's one
thing it's if it's like verbal
confrontation but it's another thing
when you step to a woman I'll teleport
there. Just let me know next time you
see him on the corner. I'll teleport.
>> You know what? By the grace of Allah.
All right. So, uh I'm going to I'm going
to head out. Let you grab the next.
>> But wait before you let me go. Just like
give it like one second. Okay. And then
go ahead. Do it. Watch your head.
>> This girl, I've never seen somebody so
happy to have watch your head done to
them, man. My sister Harvest Noel, how
you doing? You're you're muted if you're
uh
>> I'm sorry. Hi. Praise the Lord. Logic
and IP. Nice to meet you.
>> Chill.
>> Uh two things.
>> Yes.
>> Number one, I was I almost came through
the my laptop screen.
>> That black Hebrew Israelite guy.
almost can't believe how you how dare
you mess with logic.
>> I'm sorry to be putting through I be
causing y'all stress to go up.
>> Love it. And number two,
>> I can't have you out here catching a
case. No, I can't I can't
>> I don't mind. I'm old. They're not going
to do nothing to me.
>> That's See, that's crazy.
>> But you know, it's for a good cause,
though.
>> Um number two, um
>> the Trinity I do understand,
>> but my problem is sharing it. M
>> and so I wrote it down and you know how
I would share this not long and I'm
going to read off and you guys stop me
if I'm wrong.
>> Okay, this is this is how I would share
it you know with someone. One God, three
persons, father, son, holy spirit,
eternal distinct co-equal, not three
gods. It's a perfect, inseparable,
eternal communion between the Father who
creates and governs, the Son who saves
and reveals, the Holy Spirit who dwells
and transforms. He was a God who was
never alone, who lived within perfect
communion within himself. How did I do?
>> Where's my Where's the chef at? I'll put
it up. Good. Yeah, that's beautiful.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> Okay, good. cuz you know cuz I'm a
little nervous about you know sharing
that because a lot of people have a
problem with him being one God but
revealing himself through flesh and then
sent the Holy Spirit.
>> Yeah. I mean yeah the the way that you
broke it down and and that's what I what
I like about it is
>> it was very simple.
>> Yes.
>> Very straightforward.
>> Yeah.
>> And so that's what the trinity is. And
you even gave um some of the operations
of each person and that's that that was
that was really good. Now on top of
that, I don't know if you already do you
already have examples
uh scripture examples to back up, you
know, what you're saying about the role.
It it would be good to add scripture
references for each thing you said,
right?
>> One God showing scripture references
that's very clear, explicit, there's
only one God, right? um scripture
reference that shows the role and
operation of the father, son and holy
spirit, right? How the father is
creator. You can go to like 1
Corinthians 8, one god, the father from
whom are all things,
>> right? The lord, one lord Jesus Christ
through whom are all things,
>> right? You go to the verse about one
spirit, right? One baptism, one spirit
who gives the gifts and transforms and
regenerates. So use these verses for as
just to have in your pocket to back up
what you're saying. Yeah.
>> Oh, great. Thank you. I didn't think
about that.
>> Okay. I would definitely be doing my
homework on this one, but I just wanted
to see, you know, if I at least, you
know, had it to where I could share with
somebody to where they can understand it
because a lot of people think that they
can use their logic.
>> Yeah. with trying to figure God out,
>> you know, and and the Trinity and who
even who he is
>> when it's just simple faith. He says,
"Just come with faith and trusting and
believing him, you know." So,
>> and I always tell them, even when I'm in
your chat and they, "Well, who is this?"
And and and it's not real and I said,
"The reason why it's illogical to you is
because you don't know the God of the
Bible."
>> You know, when you get to know him and
you have his spirit, then it makes
sense. it becomes clear. So, thank you
so much and and IP to you too. Um I
watch you too. So, thank you for um the
time that you guys put in, you know, to
teach us and then to to minister to the
Muslims because you guys are planting
seeds.
>> Yes, ma'am. Um watch when you go and and
start digging for those verses to back
up your statements. You're going to see
how those verses stick with you ever
from that point forward. They're going
to stick with you.
>> Okay. Okay. Praise
do that. Thank you so much. And tell
Lady Logic I said hello.
>> I enjoyed her. Um, and I'll say this and
go. I enjoyed her takedown.
>> Hey,
>> I looked at that. She was she's so
gracious and she's so softspoken. I
said, "Oh, child. Look at this girl."
>> She gonna love this.
>> I'm telling you, she was like I was
like, "Jesse mad." Jesse,
>> but I see why she was because Lady Logic
cut her and she didn't even know she was
cut until she left the video.
>> I'm telling you, she's a slicer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I love
>> God bless you guys.
>> God bless you, too. Thank you. Thank
you, Noel. Love you, sis.
>> Love you, too. Bye. Bye.
>> Bye. Bye.